is a frail old woman whose elderly years
have been spent in a nursing home but
whose late teenage years was spent
working for the commandant of the
stuttoff Concentration Camp as his
secretary she would type out orders for
the mistreatment and then eventual
murder of many thousands of people
prove what she wrote We analyzed all the
documents which still exist from the
concentration camp and researched for
his signature and her initials which was
an incredible amount of work you can't
compare that to the trials against
concentration camp watch guards
in her closing statement before the
verdict Faulkner had said she was sorry
for all that had happened at stutoff and
that she regretted having been there at
the time in the nearly six years of its
existence the camp housed as many as 110
000 prisoners in atrocious conditions
it's estimated more than half of them
died there either through starvation
brutal working conditions or deliberate
killing after the war polish authorities
prosecuted some of those who'd worked at
stuttoff five of the women guards they
captured were convicted and executed by
contrast for many years neither East nor
West German authorities pursued many
who'd worked at the camp through the
courts only in the last few years has
that changed with trials like this one
the
the court has decided that through her
work as a shorthand typist at the
Concentration Camp the accused knowingly
and willingly supported the cruel death
of more than 10 500 prisoners through
gassing through the inhumane conditions
at the camp through transfers to the
Auschwitz birkenau concentration camp
and through death marches
stuttoff was just one Camp among the
many in the Nazi system its death toll
was dwarfed by that of Auschwitz and of
Treblinka and yet by bringing imgad
fergner to just this modern prosecutors
have done what generations of post-war
predecessors so often failed to do
actively pursue those who had a hand in
the Machinery of mass murder Dominic
Kane Al Jazeera Berlin